[Music]
foreign
got on the latinx train in an article
titled forget about Latino why I'm all
for latinx and you should be too writer
Yesenia funes uh hailed the term latinx
as a needed response to the male
dominant Spanish language
now most of us probably hadn't realized
that an entire language needs a response
but Salon realized and they explained
that latinks is a superior word devised
by quote feminist and queer Spanish
speakers it is in fact they said
revolutionary because it's inclusive of
those who live outside the gender binary
the article continued quote
that includes people like arigani de
Silva a Venezuelan race and sexuality
educator they are 29 and have used they
them pronouns for a little less than a
decade but they always knew that's how
they felt the Silva just didn't know
genderqueer was a possible identity now
they can add latinx as an identity too I
can understand some hesitance to the
term latings after all X isn't a letter
widely used in the Spanish language so
it might not feel organic rolling off
the tongue de Silva understands that too
but it is what it is
it is what it is how could you argue
with that
case settled
especially now the race and sexuality
educator has ruled on the subject then
you know just is what it is Salon
followed orders and they published many
articles in the past five years which
adopted the latinx term articles with
headlines like Hollywood's latinx
representation is dismal why don't
movies look more like America
and also Hollywood is still overlooking
latinx filmmakers my story matters my
pain matters
there was even an article published last
month about the the magic of Miami's
modern Daiquiri and it tells us that
Daiquiris are quote a tangible
representation of the relationship
between Cuba latinx culture and Miami
but it seems that sacred bond has now
been broken at least as far as Salon is
concerned
um this article was published by the
outlet yesterday it says stop using
latinx if you really want to be
inclusive
the writer Melissa Ochoa explains that
though when she first heard letings in
2017 she thought it was Progressive and
inclusive she has now realized that
there's a there's a dark underbelly to
this particular form of gibberish
damning it with the harshest term
available to a leftist she has declared
the term problematic
Ochoa explains that first of all
nobody in the actual Latino Community
uses the term you know she says that the
term was invented and is being pushed by
american-born academics mostly the
marginalized communities it's meant to
represent don't like it don't want it
she says that this makes the entire
thing kind of elitist and patronizing
she even points out that latinx erases
sex distinctions and situations where
she would prefer to keep them in place
so for example she says like when you
use the word latinx to describe Hispanic
women in fields where they are quote
underrepresented we're only further
obscuring their contributions
finally she observes that the X affixed
to the word
is not pronounceable in Spanish language
and she also wonders how far this will
go
to refer to someone from Mexico or
Argentina do we have to Now call them
mexicanics and argentinx
it's it's a slippery slope she says
this is what Ochoa is arguing
and it sounds exactly like
everything I've been saying about this
issue for the past five years and
everything that all of us on the right
have been saying we have been making all
of these exact arguments ever since we
first heard about this nonsense
but it will not Shock you to learn that
Salon is not going to credit us with
enlightening them on this topic or
winning the argument they're not going
to acknowledge us at all
um no they're going to pretend that they
arrived to this conclusion on their own
and worse
they're going to find a way somehow to
double down even while backing down
this is a move that is uh that is uh you
only find on the left and they're very
good at to back down while also doubling
down the writer continues many academics
might feel compelled to continue to use
latings because they fought hard to have
it recognized by their institutions or
they've already published a term in an
academic Journal
but there's a much better gender
inclusive alternative one that's been
largely overlooked by the U.S academic
community and is already being used in
Spanish-speaking parts of Latin America
especially among young social activists
in those countries it's uh Latina
so that's
l-a-t-i-n-e Latina
not Latina Latina
and it's far more adaptable she says to
the Spanish language it could be
implemented as articles less instead of
laws or loss the words for the when it
comes to pronouns L can become a
singular form of they and used in place
of the masculine l or feminine Ella
which translate to he and she it can
also be readily applied to most
nationalities such as Mexicana or
Argentina
I believe Latina Latina accomplishes
what latinx originally meant to and more
similarly it eliminates the gender
binary and its singular and plural form
however Latina is not confined to an
elite English-speaking population within
the U.S it is inclusive
language matters Latina embodies that
inclusivity across socioeconomic status
citizenship education gender identity
age groups and Nations while honoring
the Spanish language in the process
well this is the most you can really
ever expect from the left these days
every once in a while astray like Ochoa
here will wander dangerously close to
the precipice of rationality and then
right before taking the final Plunge
tumble back in the same direction she
came from
indeed all of the very true and valid
criticisms of latinx that she made or
rather we made and then she claimed
credit for are abandoned and ultimately
contradicted by her proposed solution
she is still proposing manipulating a
language to suit the needs and desires
of an academic Elite
she is still advocating something that
nobody in the Latino Community uses or
will use she is still erasing sex
distinctions
so Latina has all of the same problems
of latinx except that it arguably may be
sounds slightly less stupid slightly
she seemed for a moment tempted But
ultimately could not bring herself to
Simply say because this is all that
needs to be said
simply say to the so-called non-binary
people get over yourselves
we aren't going to change an entire
language to suit you
just deal with it your pretentious
egomaniacs
not say that and so she will inevitably
be stuck always catering to the whims of
the most narcissistic and self-involved
people on her side of the ideological
divide
and she will do this even at her own
expense
at the expense of her culture and her
language
what she cannot see
what nobody on the left can see
because if they could see it they'd no
longer be on the left
is that Universal inclusiveness
is not a virtue
it's also not coherent or possible
you cannot include everything in
anything because if you try you only you
only end up turning the thing into
nothing or else you end up including a
group while excluding another
see the most that inclusion can ever
hope to be
um at least this kind of leftist version
of inclusion is a lateral move it's kind
of a it's a trade-off
you swap one excluded group for another
only the group excluded in the name of
inclusion is usually the group that by
All rights should be the most included
and the group included is the one that
by All rights should not be included at
all so the manipulation of the Spanish
language is the perfect example of this
as it includes these pompous LGBT
obsessed academics while excluding the
everyday average Spanish-speaking people
who've been using this language for
centuries
without a problem
they don't see a problem here
this is a problem created by academic
elites on the left
here's a general rule and this this you
could just like take to the bank okay
if everyone is doing something without
an issue
and then you come along and you're the
only one having a problem
that's probably because you are the
problem
but usually inclusion simply means
destroying that which everyone is being
included in
because when everyone is included in the
definition of the word woman the word
ceases to have all meaning when the
borders are erased and everyone is
included as a citizenship as a citizen
Citizenship ceases to have all meaning
when every shape is included in the word
square squares cease to have all meaning
I am not an advocate for inclusiveness
because I would prefer for everything to
be known and seen for what it is and
treated accordingly
you know not everything can be
everything in fact nothing can be
everything
or else everything will be nothing
now I've kind of confused myself
which I think is sort of the point
and the real point for us is that salon
despite coming precariously close to a
logical viewpoint
still landed A Million Miles Away and
thus is today canceled and that'll do it
for us for this portion of the show as
we move over to the members block hope
to see you there if not talk to you
tomorrow Godspeed
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]